Dwyer and i'm joined by mr. Andrew Brown
and Eric tay which must mean one thing
we're talking about overwatch 04 watch
that's the that's the we should see
Michael phrase that happens when you
boot the game right I'm the beta no no
just make that up it's just how we say
it ever since that one trip over well
it's almost been 12 months since we
drove our asses down to anaheim to play
overwatch for the first time when he
announced it at blizzcon 2014 and today
the beta opens up a closed beta super
closed it seems invite-only lots of
leaves that's her weep that's a you've
got that we got my account still hasn't
unlocked so if you work at blizzard
Please Please Please Please Please and
it kind of sucks that we get to talk
about it and no one can like join us
completely matches yay unless you're
lucky enough to be one of the people
that got in somehow if you're a youtuber
like you're probably killing us yeah
right though but that's cool but yet so
Tay hasn't played it in a year we played
it just a few weeks ago yes we did it
may have shifted in a little bit of form
but it's basically the same game there's
18 heroes and I think it right now in
beta yep and it's like four or five
different maps which any time it's not
like you're locked in for the whole
match as many people can be as many
heroes at the same time you have like a
team of all tracers which I've always
wanted to do and get gameplay that's
maybe we should try that later yeah
terrible idea I dude I don't know though
cuz like Tracy are super good if you're
good anyway yeah I'll varying abilities
in these characters like super different
on each one there's but the but they're
divided up into like tank it has lots of
health support which either makes you
run faster or heels defensive well yeah
kind of covers a lot which is builders
and turret and snipers which is off and
this is obvious or like just people that
shoot stuff yeah and tracer who's
awesome who'd like the poster girl is
that your favorite so far do you think
both heroes here no I've never actually
played traits oh really yeah um is
Bastion still Opie no I well I just suck
it I'm the wrong person asked that
because apparently I can't get kills
anymore in over all right I guess we
spend my word yeah I spent that morning
what about you guys like yeah Eric
what's above what's been like for you
coming back after like a year of not
playing it it's still a lot of fun I
want to give credit where credit's due
it granted it as a beta but the UI is
gone
a lot better than what it was before
there's a lot of like good you know just
helpful beginner tips you know
everything that you need to know about
your hero you can easily access with f1
I mean yes the game is pretty much like
four buttons but every like hero or
however whatever you want to call them
you know does things differently they
have different movement mechanics and
different like you know left click right
click but yeah it's it's still a lot of
fun I like Andy it took it's taking a
little bit to get back into it I'm still
having loads of fun it's just that I'm
not dominating like we were that one
time I guess so so I think it's just
getting used to that and I think also
for me personally I haven't played a
keyboard mouse shooter in so long I
guess me I want my destiny I played halo
a destiny rust so I'm on that those
thumbsticks shut off opposable thumbs
instead of you know the precision of a
mouse which is what I used to like
clamor about so right now it's closed
and it seems like this might be going on
indefinitely yes what haven't said but
by the looks of it and what they did
with heroes perhaps this will just be it
until the games out and they've also
said that they're going to have open
weekends for rice stress testing yeah
they haven't said when exactly it's
going to be but if you're interested in
playing over watch and make sure that
you opt into the beta stuff on battlenet
because yeah they're going to be opening
this up for everyone else and a couple
of like cool things though to that
speaking to like blizzard doing betas
basically they can change like any of
this of course like yeah I the same time
what can we do yeah but one of the big
things that they've kind of done is they
got rid of a leaderboard when you press
tab or whatever yet the source ring so
and they've also made a distinction
between eliminations and finishers so
talk about that I'm not quite because
letter because the interesting can take
about that that's you know usually when
you hit tab on a on a FPS FPS it says it
ranks them baby like pills whatever
points and I thought that that seemed
like a kind of a piecemeal change but it
actually does kind of change yeah like
the feet it pushes people towards a team
play that I feel like a lot of other
games even like CS and stuff okay you're
all do right you just want to be on top
of the leaderboard and in this a lot of
the heroes actually don't finish other
heroes like I don't get that blow
the killing blow but they do a lot of
damage that they do a lot of support or
they get you there in the battle faster
or the soak up damage yeah it is like a
huge part of the games just soaking up
damage I think that's that's another
like fun element that makes this game
like that like more appealing because
you can play differently right like if
you play mercy and you play support the
whole time you can heal or you can give
buff damage and you don't even have to
do any damage if you don't watch it but
her secondary like her pistol is
actually pretty good from last time I
played it and so you know you have
varying styles of play you know like you
want to try to make a team that's kind
of cohesive and like kind of
well-rounded and even the even the
tutorial or that the you i will tell you
hey by the way you don't have that many
offensive players on your team so maybe
one of you guys should switch kind of
thing right like you don't have to but
it's like oh you don't have any tanks at
the moment yeah we have too many healers
or something like not too many support
people with terrible actually yeah
opposite [ __ ] nightmare and you can
switch like I said before like the cool
thing is while they don't match and it's
like all right we need to kind of step
up a little bit more something and I'm
like any more damage I'm even more tanky
stuff so I'm like I'll switch to the ape
guy Winston Winston get in there and
mess up but not because you haven't been
playing good with somebody else
necessary necessarily but perhaps
because yeah exactly like maybe this the
tactics have changed I was playing as am
I forget that one of the snipers who
like launches oh no she supports but she
also like throws mines up but she makes
the total acreage oh no no that's a
whatever her name oh yeah she's got
crazy thing out there but I was playing
his her and then after a while and it
didn't make any sense for me to be
making the teleporter because we've been
pushed back so far so I was like right
I'll swap to somebody else so it is a
lot of like on-the-fly sort of team
tactics which I guess really does push
this into the eSports sort of area which
is that is very much what Blizzard are
trying to do what do you think about
that Eric I think that when you if it
does if and when it does get to that
point i think that the game is going to
be accessible for everyone but when it
hits that kind of esports level they're
gonna probably have draft modes right
which will be kind of weird because like
that's not how this game may be is meant
to play casually but like in terms of
eastwards there's probably gonna be
picks and bans i wouldn't be surprised
you know
like this see like certain players
playing specific roles almost mobile s
great because again you have tank
offensive support so like I wouldn't be
shocked to see kind of locked in modes
for one map and the maps are pretty fast
like they're five to ten minutes
sometimes you get the extended over time
and stuff like that but it's interesting
though that that was brought up when we
were a blizzard and they sort of replied
saying that they haven't ruled that
doing any of that stuff but especially
at this stage with the beta I think
they're keeping all options open they're
keeping the gameplay is open as possible
and then they sort of alluded to the
fact that perhaps later they might start
to trim down some of the choice within
different game modes but right now they
very much seem to be kind of let's throw
out all these characters all these gay
modes and then you know figure out what
people are like warming to or not I
guess that one of the things I want ask
you guys about is that the game mode
specifically seems to be the one area in
which it's rather traditional like they
have a yet the sort of the what is that
load at mode which is in T fortress
halo-halo dearly Fortress 2 and the rest
of the stuff is pretty much normal
everything yeah sort of different
variants on that and is that something
that sort of concerns you guys about or
is there enough variety with Andy within
the characters the heroes themselves to
keep you happy I never thought of it
that way because man like i right it's
been such like I just want to play more
I don't play more and every chance we
get it's like who cares what the math
they're like yeah so I don't know it'll
be weird to see if it gets old or
something or like you start to see
through the cracks a little bit yeah
like oh the payload it's easy to defend
this cuz you just set up like two
turrets to like bastions and everybody
else is a tank like a long harsh of the
front yeah yeah so like it's it'll be
cool to see that stuff like
crowd-sourced whatever I mean it'll be a
min maxing of like once people figure
out maps there's like so many spots that
people haven't even figured out or you
start dying and you're like oh where the
heck is that person you're like oh
they're all the way up there because
they figured out that they could go
there so do you remember them up where
we went before where there was a choke
point and we basically put up two
turrets who put up a sentinel or bastion
and we put up the the other guy the the
little
a little norm born or for every wharf
yeah yeah they said in that way it was a
weave we in this map basically got
everyone then that choke point just
blaze them they never had a chance right
and apparently in that map there was a
place you could fly over the top that
when we played at a blizzard there was
an entire new route to the left where
they could flank so they've already
changed lots of them up so I wonder you
know you're right there probably keep
updating this for the next couple of
weeks and months that was for sure
something I noticed after not playing
for a year it's like yeah it seems like
when you start there's kind of like
either two or three ways you're going to
exit your starting point to wherever you
need to go there's like the main
entrance door and then there's like two
little side doors and that was like a
team fortress problem as well during the
start team fortress two is that a lot of
the places when you got right at the
gates if they decided to like dump on
you right yeah you they could actually
pin you in there for yeah you could have
to work your way out of there and that
happened like sometimes at the first
press yeah I was pitting people against
the wall soon as they walk out as
reinhardt just like doing the slam and
it was really pissing people off and and
that I don't know if anybody's gonna
jump in this game on the open weekends
they're probably gonna get worked and
then they're gonna yeah because that can
happen like Josh other guy here he was
like all right over watch I got it and
after he like didn't like have a good
match yeah he's like I'm not good please
they have one character in there because
that was the thing i think that sort of
shocked all of their shocked all the
surprises that was how different each
character is it doesn't sound like
classes within the same thing they do
very much feel like they have unique
abilities because they do but i love has
one character in there which is
basically a call of duty soldier and
earthquake so everyone's like unique
movement ability on shift and his one is
just roaring yeah it's like the only one
that's a pretty fun i played of this now
he's pretty standard like here's your
standard FPS guys kolik soldier
photo/jeffrey 76 76 mm yeah but he's
he's the guy that like if you're
starting i think if i think even the
tutorial makes you use him i reek so I'm
not shocking like here's your set guy
that you can kind of start with that you
tried and true you you know how to play
them you know what I mean and then just
start nibbling the dabbling here and
there but yeah I mean like like you said
it could be hard to get into if you get
rolled a couple times in the beginning
but I mean me Rob and my cat-like side
side
back here like we were playing halo war
zone and then we got rolled and it was
like oh that sucks you know I mean like
that's going to happen with I think FPS
shooter than I think you just have to
have a little bit of patience and then
find your hero I think once you find one
in your heroes you're like start kicking
butt you're like all right I'm gonna use
this guy for a while then movie maybe
move off for a little while I'm trying
to see do I need to go back but always
have that safety net go back a lot of
opportunities for people have become
player coaches on youtube like oh yeah
we're like do those videos like here's
how to play yo man we want to be sick
reinhardt that's what you gonna do there
is pretty involved dude like yeah
there's people at blizzard talking to
you the whole time when you're playing
at the events they're like all right so
do this all right jump out and they're
like I'm combinations right yeah all
right now try to like blend you should
do this yeah oh man I totally changes
the whole thing up like we'd ride hard
and then I was that was about the
brazilian dude who's got the blues yeah
the beatbox and if I doubled him up a
right hat certainly wine harms it's like
super fast so anyway we're getting
pretty deep it's for a game that's still
in closed beta and thanks very much guys
for coming on talking to overwatch I
enjoy watching you play while I wait for
my battlenet I can to unlock for the
rest of the week we need you man if you
are interested at all in overwatch make
sure you sign up on your belt on that
account opt into the beta stuff there
and so you can get in on those open
weekends but in the meantime if or if
you don't get in at all let us know dick
about watch if you watch any of our
coverage on gamespot com over the past
couple of weeks and months we're
definitely big fans of it and we like to
know what you guys think of it as well
stick your thoughts in the comment box
below